[Music]
it's been several hours and 15 days
since you took hey babe away
oh
I go out every night and sleep baby
since you took hey babe away
[Music]
since you've been gone I could do
whatever I want
I could see whoever I choose
I could eat my dinner in a fancy
restaurant
but nothing I said nothing can take away
these Blues cause now
and compares
Nothing Compares hey babe
[Music]
Sinead O'Connor R.I.P all right Ben said
with Sinead O'Connor's death brings life
Jared fried is here what a tribute I
gotta say I don't think I'll ever be
able to erase the image of Chris doing
the odds
that was great I couldn't take my eyes
off we lose we lose one Irish Catholic
we gain a Massachusetts Jew
[Laughter]
[Music]
in a way I was because it's one of those
things where this is the new thing with
guys I'm always a bit behind the fashion
trend guys you're bringing men are now
bringing the Capri pant back it's back
oh yeah it's not a capri pants so much
as a high cup I did it I wrote Hungary a
little high cuff dungaree here's the
thing I you you know you want to be
loved or you want to be hated you don't
want to be meh you don't want to have no
one have no opinion on I like that so
they're you know again for the women out
there I've been like polling women and
some of them are like the cuff I
couldn't get wet if I went on a water
slide then some of them were like love
the cuff right so so I'm willing to go
let's Love Me Or Hate Me yes that's what
you want because in the middle is boring
nobody cares you didn't commit like I
didn't commit on the sound O'Connor but
you've committed with the pants and now
and that's what I that and that's good I
also came in here smelling like a full
hazelnut I spilled a full coffee onto
myself I don't smell it but you know I
smell it let me smell your balls get in
here yeah get in here get out you know
there we go wow that's a full hazelnut
that's a nut that's not just my knots I
smell like sweat of God I think you
smell like um what's that candle shop
with all those scents oh uh like a
Yankee Candle yeah I'm okay with that
that could be my smell like a Yankee
Candle like fall like pumpkin like
whatever I'm off of season that's the
only problem there this the full iced
coffee spill to me and I go to this one
coffee place in um the West Village and
they know me and they like it's called
Uh Starbucks
called Starbase
do you know when
no one Chicago and my buddy we were all
like getting hammered we're in Chicago
and he's like hey tonight we're eating
big it's this little Mom and Pop shop
called dominoes and we're gonna go and
we're gonna have the best meal of our
life and the whole night we're going oh
my God I can't wait I have dominoes it's
gonna be great he's like oh it's a
Chicago stable you're gonna love it we
go back to this apartment he was like
yeah we're getting dominoes we're like
it but I I'm at Blackstone uh Roasters
uh whatever and then the guy just sees
me just fill a full spillful iced coffee
on myself okay so at least you get to
have coffee though it's not like you
spilled it and then you had no coffee no
no they gave it on another one and they
said and then they did the thing like
get them out of here you're in the way
like we need to clean this how did you
spill it what happened on the table
outside is a little wobbly but I'm lucky
it was a black coffee wobbly table what
I hate a wobbly table but I love sitting
at this place I sit at this place out
like all day I sit out there yeah how do
you guys take your coffee black black
black no sugar no zero sugar black it
burnt it the fast if I don't want to
break a fast with a coffee so I do black
coffee oh my coffee makes it so you
don't eat
black coffee I just feel like I can I
like to taste the coffee there's no
reason to put the extra calories in the
coffee I'm not doing coffee for not even
sweetener no I do black you do blacks
and dry I do like my black friend
when I have coffee I'm not a big huge
coffee guy but I do black or drop of
drop drop drop of oat
skim
or almond drop off no sugar three
together at one time no no oh one to the
other one
I'm on the Bender I do all three drops
you have a mix of Odin skin
you go full black with a little
sweetener extra ice Sweet and Low extra
extra ice no it's not 1984. Grandma
sugars I'm putting Sweet and Low wait a
minute
I don't want nothing depresses me more
than the melted ice sitting at the top
we have an iced coffee I have to throw
it away going in hot coffee into ice and
letting it cold they're not cold Brewing
it no they got cold I'm saying I just
you know it wouldn't melt after a while
I need the ice to last the whole drink
a little thermostat
I would lose it
get a free tumbler when you order go use
the code code hey babe I mean those
tumblers people love like it's an
amazing gift it's a whole thing like I
do a bit about the big water bottle like
on the special but I've been doing it on
the road and it's just like if you
mention big water bottle you just see
like a guy and his girl like him like
some guy like shaking his girlfriend
like you got a big water bottle people
go and then I'm like and then you ask
them they're like they're like she's got
the big water bottle she's a piece of
people love calling out if you have a
big water bottle like someone around you
is like waiting to call me and I think
you should leave sketch mode
you got something to prove like you have
to drink your ounces in body weight I
hate it
that's usually a company with I'm
fasting right I'm saying it's a health
thing it's it is you're flying a flag of
a certain to let people know you're
about you're better than them yeah the
ones with the words on the side like
that's a douchebag I hate it and I I
just think it's just like you know you
see people and then you ask them how
many ounces and they're like
152. you're like yeah are you like
always in the bathroom like what's going
on yeah I saw a girl I saw a girl did
some like there's a new challenge
something 75 like 75 days in a row you
do workouts and this and that Google 75
day challenge water poisoning this girl
went to the hospital because she drank
too much water
yeah God yeah tick tocker said she had
to go to hospital while attempting a
fitness challenge called 75 hard that's
a story so she's from Flint that's what
she's from Flint yeah
yeah she should have known it's been a
couple years now
um no that's like a story my mom would
pick up and then have to reference even
if you drink water like you know like
nothing can be not like a mom will hear
that story like my mom heard a story
about I I told her my laptop I bring it
into bed with me to like watch movies
and masturbate sure yeah so I'm telling
my mom this and she's like she goes no
no a bed caught on fire from from a
laptop being on the bed and I'm like can
you not put that in my head yeah that's
not gonna happen all my mother does is
Stoke Terror like panic and Terror to me
that's every text she does but except
except yesterday she texted me an
Instagram clip of a Christian r b Duo
that's yeah
it just was like just this is nice I
think it was nice sometimes you hear
like a Christian rock music and you're
like a minute in and you're like this is
this is the new summer thing and then
you're like well maybe you hit the Riff
and you don't know it's Christian yeah
you don't know it's great and then you
hear a praise be and you're like oh
I gotta get out of here I could have
liked this yeah yeah it was a ruined
something look at this nurses are more
likely to cheat on their significant
other more than athletes musicians and
DJs two out of three women admitted to
cheating at work as well at work
something about being a nurse and being
a flight attendant I think it makes
people horny maybe I think flight
attendant definitely the time zone stuff
the Circadian rhythm gets messed up but
nurses I think because they deal with so
much sick and death that they like look
at their life every day and they're like
am I happy at home and then they're just
getting mad at their husband or
boyfriend for something next thing you
know they're suck yeah
yeah that's it that's one Theory or the
other is just that most nurses are
you know that's true I think also
outfits by the way I just want to real
quick if you guys are looking for a
great bid on nurses check out Joe
derose's bed
oh it's a good one
I think it's the outfits something about
what a nurse wears to work to me is like
a body pillow right like I want to
snuggle up to the scrubs the scrubs are
just snuggle a little bull yeah yeah you
know I I I knew a girl that was not a
nurse uh allegedly that was not a doctor
at all but had literally like months
supply of Scrubs because she would just
order them online and sleep in them and
I thought about in the pandemic I was
like this has taken like equipment
away from actual medical First
Responders so she could be cute and
comfy in bed right but people have done
that all over the world I sleep in 95s
so I yeah
on your face
together a bunch of n95s to make my
pajamas
that's how I get my fire going I I use
it as Tinder
make sure that I can get it warm in the
apartment dude you think it's because I
you know what it is I think it's because
I think it's because of the shifts
anything you go in and do like a 48 hour
shift yeah you're almost living a chunk
of a different life during that time
right you know what I mean yeah are you
attracted to nurses and and Fighters
like I I do I I find myself they're also
on stage you know just in the way we're
on stage if someone looks at you and
goes wow I'm looking at them for a
little bit longer I'm getting used to
their look I think a flight attendant a
nurse they're on stage they walk into
the room
so they're looking at them and getting
used to them that's a huge Freud you
know counter transference where it was
like a thing where it's like obvious how
like if we were sick and a nurse nursed
us back to health our bodies like I'm
falling in love with this woman because
she helped me but then sometimes because
you're falling in love with her or him
it gets counter transferred back they
start to fall in love with you it's like
a phenomenon that's what happens with
actors that's when people start dating
in the movie when they play a lot of
interest in a movie right have you ever
been on a flight and you're sitting
there and you're like this flight
attendant's the most gorgeous woman I've
ever seen and then you're like she's not
me I'm in Delta Comfort yeah
like there's no way
she's gonna be like no get away from me
first class successful people yeah
Delta Comfort being like wow do you
think we could fall in love in what
world is she like get away from me
businessman you might be the happy
medium right right really pretentious
people up in the front people that maybe
don't have a lot of motivation all the
way in the back just saying maybe maybe
I'm just saying maybe like well this is
fine theoretical you're the unmotivated
I've been recording I've been motivated
but you're right you're a happy mix yeah
I was invited I Target Comfort actually
I would love if they started calling the
the Lesser classes the unmotivated I
would die if they're like okay
right
at the people with children people that
need extra help active military want
that you know million mile Members First
group two groups
yes and the Sal vulcano unmotivated yeah
there's no overhead space for the
unmotivated
we know you guys didn't pack much
you guys slept in too much yeah they
don't even give you food they just give
a jar of food and just chips
that's good for the next few trips yeah
I just would love that to get attached
to you I used to be this big Sal fan
then he's just started
once a year I I'm saying if she's
looking at you in that way if she's
looking at you in that way that would
that would mean that she's looking at
the people behind you in a different way
but I'm saying as far as what makes you
attractive to a woman yeah you go you
know you go okay well why would what if
you were like a a shark right okay
you're wealthy but uh first class was
sold out and you need to get somewhere
online you can't judge a story it's just
created yes to convince herself to want
to be with me all right you have to
think too all day every flight they must
get hit on that's what that is
hit on if you're a semi-attractive It's
gotta suck I've never hit on a flight
attendant I will say
one and an attractive the only time in
my life an attractive flight attendant
walked over to talk to us knelt down and
then just talked to us like for like a
half hour and kept coming back and kept
talking to us the whole flight for no
reason and then at the end she gave me
her number really yeah and I was gonna
call you in first class
of course I I don't recall you were not
an unmotivated class I don't recall I
don't remember when it was right but it
probably was within the last 10 years so
maybe we were right I don't know I was
flying with my dad maybe I was if I'm
playing with my special moment though
like yeah my dad was like
oh my God this doesn't happen this has
never happened before and she was very
very pretty yeah yeah very good looking
but I never called
if you're listening you know if you're
out there you know I'm just you know
okay I know you can't you instead of
calling somebody call Jared freed he's
got a new special coming out called 37
and single that's right on Netflix baby
when does it come out August 15th August
15th this puppy comes out so it's coming
out in what two weeks from now two three
weeks from now it's coming out 37 and
single it's out there that's on Netflix
go watch go enjoy it's all fun and games
dude it's uh yeah it's a good time now
because they're not making nobody's
making any original new content so you
got nothing else new to watch you might
as well watch Jared Freed's special
huge plug
yeah so you might as well you got
nothing
if you're unmotivated go back and watch
the all of our episodes previously
now here's here's the thing the big news
of the day that's straight up officially
with regular human teeth I'm looking at
a fish with regular straight up nice
nice human teeth but uh but I'm looking
at that upper and I'm saying that that
might be nice to stick your pee pee into
yeah
the dichotomy of teeth on this fish yeah
it's gums and straight up very nice
white straight humans veneers on the
bottom crackhead on the top really yeah
and now what the uh close related to the
piranha but with human-like teeth yeah
so this brings me to a point because we
got big we got because when you look at
something like that you say literally
out of this world and then human to make
no mistake it doesn't look like human
teeth those are human teeth on a fish
those are fully human that that thing is
bicuspids so so but that brings me it
needs some braces but that brings me to
what I want to talk about today is the
biggest news of the century came out
today
as tweeted out by Nicole Snooki police
eat snooky snookies I saw that Snooki
told me this I'm snooky said and then I
said what is going on Snooki said I saw
this treaty she said I literally want to
cry but what is happening at the UFO
hearing history
finally the public gets to hear what
we've all known and thought Snooki I'm
with you I've been thinking it
to the Congress today the United States
of America the number one country in the
world Jared's wearing the flag on his
shirt you better watch this special or
else you're Communists they announced
aliens are real this is listen to this
listen
listen to this
today we lost Sinead today to the end
get out of here yeah the aliens are
coming listen to this this is from he's
an i i i I'll have a panic attack this
podcast sponsored by better help let me
tell you something trusting yourself to
make decisions that align with your
values it's like anything the more you
practice it the easier it gets babe and
that can be done with therapy okay you
have to make tough choices in life
sometimes you need a little guidance you
don't have to go at it all by yourself
so if you've been thinking of starting
therapy or ever thought about therapy
why not give better help a try all you
got to do is fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and you switch
therapists any time for no additional
charge the whole thing is online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule they can't make
it any easier let therapy be your map
with better help what do we got to tell
them visit betterhelp.com hey babe today
and you'll get 10 off your first month
that's better health help.com hey babe
you know about the game time app last
minute ticket deals I used to really
guarantee them you get to see where
you're sitting from the sort of the
Viewpoint of your seat I love it I'm
about to I don't know if I can go see
this rock the bells concert on August
5th and it's going to be a last it's
going to be a game time decision which
is and I'm honestly I'm waiting to use
this app on that day well also what I
love most about them is you know you
don't have to plan months in advance
anymore the game time app has deal has
tickets on deals right up to the event
but the biggest thing they have the game
time guarantee which means you'll always
get the best price if you find tickets
in the same section and roll for Less
game time will credit you 110 of the
difference that's humongous they have
Flash Deals uh and last minute ticket
deals easy to find for any event by the
way it's not just Sports it's concerts
it's comedy it's theater it's anything
near you forget planning months in
advance
game time has deals on tickets right up
to the day of the event yes I'm gonna go
I'm looking for salsa windfall tickets
and I'm going to use Game Time shout out
Joe DeRosa buy tickets in a matter of
seconds two Taps and you're all set
they're sent directly to your phone so
you never have to dig through an email
snag the tickets without the stress with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account and use code hey babe
for 20 off your first purchase term
supply of course again all you got to do
is create an account redeem code hey
babe 20 off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed you've said that the
government is in possession of
potentially non-human spacecraft based
on your experience and extensive
conversations with experts do you
believe our government has made contact
with intelligent extraterrestrials
something I can't discuss in public
setting guilty right that's a yes okay I
can't ask when you think this occurred
she looks like an actress who's the
actress she does do we have the bodies
as I've stated publicly already in my
news Nation interview biologics came
with some of these recoveries pretty
amazing if you can pause this for two
seconds it's pretty amazing I'm like
this is probably the biggest news we've
ever heard in our lives like I'm going
who's that hot actress
they're like UFOs exist uh we're all
going to die she is so hot that's like
that movie don't look up Leonardo
DiCaprio that movie Leonardo DiCaprio
don't look up when the asteroid is
coming they're all like not giving a
yeah at all the news just talking I
mean this is all they're talking about
today is Hunter Biden's trial they're
talking about everything else but
they're not talking about this but I
think that's on purpose they want to
like release it but not make it a big
deal I'm I'm literally I I I'm not good
I'm not good with this kind of stuff
right so what's going on right now today
what's happening what happened today let
me just and again I'm gonna paraphrase a
lot of the stuff that I'm gonna tell you
we can go deep dive in I don't know it
like the back of my hand but what I'm
about to tell you is is what I think is
the truth and what I think most of the
world read this article go ahead please
we can read it but what basically that
is an X he's an ex us intelligence
official okay that's come out with
government permission to say yes we
recovered spacecrafts we recovered
biologics meaning alien bodies that we
don't know exist that we did you know
that that we've had them now the big
thing in from Joe Rogan down to even
very respectable people like people like
this all like Snooki yeah but they all
think they all think that the real
reason that all this happened started
happening in the 1930s and the real
reasons that we had to stop the Nazis on
what the thing that the Nazis were about
mostly was they got the alien technology
all this technology and stuff first and
with Antarctica and all this stuff that
happens in Antarctica all the countries
of the world they're always Drilling in
the ice in Antarctica and they think a
lot of this stuff was in the hands of
Nazis Nazi technology Von uh Von Braun
the top scientist who made the V2 rocket
Einstein Dutch Von Dutch Von Holland
um they all think that they have this
alien type of technology and it's been
kind of known for a long time and kind
of simmering up to the public but today
a lot of people think like that's why
Snooki's crying is it's the first day
that like the government has finally
admitted like yes you know we've been
kind of throwing it out there a little
bit but now it's starting to become very
real
yeah this is all very scary oh my God
look at this a former Air Force officer
and intelligence official told Congress
Wednesday he believes the government is
hiding captured UFOs and claimed he
could not reveal whether anyone was
murdered to keep the secret detained
this is the guy David grush this is the
guy who's just on that video and he was
on TV and now they got him under arrest
and he's basically saying all this stuff
he's under oh that's the thing so the
government had to allow that he's under
oath okay but could not reveal whether
right there that the government could
have murdered someone to keep this a
secret from her I love our country I'm
wearing that American flag on Jared
freed it's on my heart right now I love
this country I am as American as it gets
you will never hear me say a bad word
but what you have to understand about
America is we're no different than
Russia North Korea we just do it in a
different more cute way but we will
absolutely murder people that government
will murder people that get it's not
just movie stuff no no no I'm not
agreeing with the government murdering
people to hold this Secret in but
wouldn't you say that we don't really
have the ability to like I'm gonna get
in trouble for saying unmotivated and
he's not going to get in trouble for
saying
[Laughter]
I'm just saying like do do you think we
have the like the fact that like the
people that come out and like see
unhinged 100 people like I don't
want Snooki to be like
anyone could have been like yeah they're
aliens anyone could have said well the
government probably saw that tweet they
were like snooky Snooki tweeted retweet
that one because then at least it takes
some of the stink off Hunter beings
half the people who say they've seen it
you have all their glasses all like this
we don't need no need and it's like we
look how we handled a pandemic we didn't
come together no it wasn't Independence
Day remember Independence Day in that
movie they had all the flags of all the
countries yeah on the side of the f-15s
and we're like yeah the world yeah yeah
we love each other none of that happened
yeah and then the guy who saved the
world was Randy Quaid
yeah no but I'm telling you like I'm
telling you there is no in my opinion
there is no coincidence at all that the
day they announce this is also the day
Hunter Biden is is had to go to court
and pled not guilty because it's all
distraction Tech it's all you think it's
more important to distract us from
Hunter Biden than it is to distract us
from Aliens I think yes I think that the
I think that the the president the
president will do what he wants to save
his son and be like you know what at
this point your son's gotta go I I
I can't believe like we have
more afraid of the capacity of humans to
handle this than I am the aliens who
might show up right you know they've
been kind of observing us for all these
but what's the you know let them up
is a lot of people believe too that
aliens probably have been here amongst
us for a long time and that we're not
all the same species that why why does
an alien have to have look like what you
see in the movies it could look like
that in some form but could also have
had the form that we are all we could be
it yeah I love what Colin Quinn says he
goes what if the aliens are all the dumb
people that's true oh no
motivated
out of this now that aliens are real
like what are the pyramids what is what
is god well that's what that's the thing
is do you think people people are so
emotional that's the thing people hold
on to their pre-existing views and fight
even harder to hold on to them so like
the God people are gonna be more God
Godly you know they're going to revert
to their corner of the god you know ring
right I don't think this gets better
it's not like we find other aliens and
the God people go all right do whatever
we want with your bodies you know like
like I don't think this makes
it should everything it should think you
would okay there's literally life
everywhere and we don't know about all
bets are off now but you would think
yeah I don't think I don't know how are
we judging anybody well then I don't
think the preacher stops preaching yeah
my when the whole Catholic Church
Scandal broke with like they were like
boys my age at the time it happened when
I was 12 13 years old my mother such a
devout Catholic he took me a beautiful
little 12 13 year old boy with blonde
hair she took me to church to pray
it's unwavering that it won't matter but
I think much like you know
aliens is a religion too Hunter Biden is
a religion at this point sure you know
like whether you're for or against him
and whatever you know one of the girls
he was pictured with like she used to be
at the comedy seller all the time yeah
one of the girls was at the Comedy
Cellar all the time like weekly at one
point the people that are there weekly I
that kind of makes some sense too yeah
you know yeah the people that are like
every day you're like you don't need
that much comedy in your life like you
might there's an issue there's something
off so my question for you guys is how
does aliens change your life at all I
think that the only way aliens would
change my life is kind of what Jared's
saying is because I'm not as devout it
would kind of make me be like well then
religion and all that things that we
were taught then it obviously can't be
real and I think it would just
fundamentally change some like structure
in the way I think about things and you
know I'd have to wonder if I'm into
aliens yeah how does this change my
games
yeah no I would be and I thought about
this before in the past before no matter
what they were like you could be
sexually attracted uh no no matter what
they look like it depends they're
aesthetic it's kind of aesthetic pending
okay aesthetic pending from from when
Wedding Crashers when uh when he Owen
Wilson
um touches the mom's boobs you know
what's that actress like the older lady
Christopher Walker's wife's okay boobs
and he like and then she like snaps out
of it like she doesn't she just want him
in touch and she goes she goes if he
goes pervert and I just said that when
you said you hit the aliens I I would be
because like I I I really think that we
need something else really yeah
why not why options are good listen you
know you know and also like we've talked
about aliens on this thing before but
today is the thing it's out right yes uh
s whether the government had possession
of such things as UFOs absolutely based
on interviewing 40 Witnesses over just
the last four years yes I know the exact
locations where the UFOs are kept and
those were provided to the Inspector
General right
non-human spacecraft is this a better
thing for us to like why here's what I
don't understand like you know we lived
our life like we're the 90s that bad for
like these older people who the hell is
that Miss Luna oh miss Luna I like Miss
Luna I'm unheard of that's right oh yeah
I like that I see that
I see I see problems for the rest of my
life and I'm saying sign me up yeah
that's that's the Matador holding a red
flag for Chris do we have bodies of the
pilots who piloted this craft she
followed up as I stated publicly the
publicly bio biologists came with some
of these recovery that means they have
aliens yeah so it's not just a
spacecraft he says they're non-human oh
my God
where the 90s so horrible for this guy
that he's like I gotta change things up
I I gotta tell people about the aliens
like right remember when we just went to
Olive Garden and had a nice night
unlimited right and now we have to live
in a world like and we had cable TV and
there were no phones and like were
things that bad that we need this now
why don't why don't we want to keep life
going as it was I I do want to and I
don't like this information what did you
just find out I was riddled with anxiety
on the reg and now this is just gonna
add to it well okay uh he did allege
that he had quote unquote personal
knowledge of people who've been harmed
or injured in efforts to cover up or
conceal these extraterrestrial
Technologies ask whether he had faced
any retaliation or reprisals himself he
said he had but declined to say more
citing there is an investigation in the
way it was very brutal and unfortunate
some of the tactics they used to hurt me
both professionally and personally to oh
my God I know that's he's saying the
government
people have big egos the government
probably doesn't care about him at all
any any Misfortune he's had in his life
he's like the government's with
me what if the government came out today
and they're like all of it's true
here are the aliens show you and Biden
unzipped his face he's a big lizard yeah
honestly would do you think we'd go do
people go into work tomorrow uh
um I think what's gonna happen uh we
said this we have proof of me saying
this three years ago I think what's
gonna happen is we're about people feel
we're on the precipice of World War I
think that the governments the powers
that be might unite us all the only way
to unite us is to have an alien threat
so we as a world Stave off our own
domination we have to now fight these
people but guess what these people these
aliens are going to be government psyops
disguised as aliens I think that's part
of the plan that is a wild Theory my
name is Randy Quaid
yeah we're going to send you up the poop
Shooters
save us all but I think that you
probably some of this stuff coming I
think really in the next few I'm saying
what not for the best of our nation this
is for Humanity there you go to
understand the magnitude of what this
means for Humanity this is an issue of
government transparency we can't trust a
government that doesn't trust its people
okay could you imagine literally like in
the 2024 election it's you know Biden
Trump or DeSantis and then there's an
octopus
an octopus has they think not only to an
octopus I stopped eating them because
they're too intelligent not only are
octopus
smarter than us they have brains every
tentacle you eat it's one of their
brains they have like a hundred brains
in one arm yeah crazy too you can't
do it uh they think they're aliens they
think they came from another planet and
were dropped here in the bottom of the
ocean they think there's many scientists
that do not think they originated on
planet Earth that they came from
somewhere else because nothing else is
like them their intelligence is so
Superior well I've only seen them choose
the Super Bowl winner what do you mean
a box I got like like it was like um you
know like taking a box out of it I've
seen those types of things but like yeah
and then you know how many brains yeah
and then one you know one of them uh
wrote a screenplay yeah
they're striking against letting
octopuses you know write movies but I
mean dude it is it's do you what about
the Vegas aliens
that was the one a few weeks ago right
the guy said things eight to ten feet
tall it's not human it's in our yard I'm
looking at it right now right it was
just Charles Barkley
and then but then the next day right you
didn't hear from them you didn't hear
any more about the story you didn't hear
about the you didn't it was totally
totally silent after that it came out it
was wild and then it and then not
another word and these people have not
come out and said anything which means
one of two things
the government gets them they came out
let me find it they did the teenager of
the family came out okay and Reddit
video okay yeah why is it so hard to
find these people afterwards because
well because I think one thing that's
happening is too with government I think
the government has to start to tell us
the truth now because I think as you
know uh exciters we're getting about
this government officials have known
about this for 50 years but it was so
much easier to contain you can't contain
it anymore when everyone has a camera so
they have to get ahead of it but I will
SnapChat ruined it for aliens I will say
there should be like a metoo movement
for people who are abducted or
discredited because they believed in
Aliens yeah think about all the stories
we heard that will probably probably
true and they they were they were
discarded as Kooks you can't listen to
them that's not real so my daughter now
goes to a Catholic School on Staten
Island so like that's like going to
Catholic School like in the 80s like
it's it they are they are not you are
they're you know they're Progressive but
it's like it's not they are they're all
aggressive for the 80s yes yeah they're
old school they're not it's not going to
be about you know any of the new
it's like old school stuff and she in
her school they talk about how there's
probably more life in other planets
they're willing to say there's more life
elsewhere yeah in a Catholic school
because it's so obvious so my daughter
now how we own eight nine years old be
like no way there could never be she's
the opposite and my 13 year old stepson
is like oh of course like he sees the
YouTube videos it's very they've always
kind of said that like the the numbers
are too large for to not it's an
impossible they've always kind of said
that that it's impossible for there not
to be anything out there right right
what they what they've also said is how
it's very possible that we may never
interact ever because they use the
example of an ocean they were like if I
there's so much life in the ocean
they're like we can all agree there's
life in the ocean right they said well
the expanse of the universe would be
like the Atlantic Ocean times a billion
right right so they said if I put if I
went into the middle of the Atlantic
ocean and I dropped the bucket into the
Middle Atlantic Ocean and all I pulled
out was water if you make the assessment
say because of this one bucket there's
no life you're an idiot he said well
that's what it is with the universe but
they're the the nearest fish from where
I am could be so far away I'll never be
able to get a bucket down low enough to
get it and that's why you may or may not
ever run into this meanwhile they've
gotten here we have to we have to
believe that they are more intelligent
than us right right but they've also
crashed and we have them captive I don't
know if we have any alive that would be
wild you also see this other theory that
it's like Us From Another Dimension
there's a lot of that what do you mean
that like there's parallel timelines and
they've found a way in that timeline to
like well that's quite some stuff now
right they've made their way here and
they go well I can't really say that
because they know no one here will
believe them so like that's like another
option so like people that are like like
do like Warren Buffett could be from
another plant because he does well in
the stock market things like that
something like that where that might be
just a way that we have to rationalize
us not being as good as someone else
right I don't know but there's a there's
other options here what do they say the
Quant the hydron collider they say that
that's the day got shifted right
there's people that say like the minute
they did that collider thing what I'm
talking about what did that happen look
at the collider the day there's like a
genius out there there's this kid I saw
a video where he was like yeah the
minute that happened like we are on a
different right playing field than we
really yeah like
Hadrian collider broke reality okay
right right so so they're saying that uh
take apart plan we dissect organisms so
uh simply put the collider allows
scientists to make particles smash into
one another so they can study the
effects and this was a few years ago
that this went down and they're like
saying that like the minute that
happened like went awry okay here
we go built over the course of 10 years
between 90 and 2008 uh 10 000 scientists
17 Mile circumference this is a big boy
keep going let's find out what it
actually did though uh even with all the
great minds uh uh
yeah something because because there's
that and then there's also that machine
that people have that they say is in the
Vatican where you can look into it and
look back into history and they say it's
only in the Vatican in the vaults deep
in the Vatican so that's that's how you
sell tickets
right right they're like oh yeah they're
like listen we got kids on one side but
which hey don't worry about that but you
want to look into the past right you
want to see what it was like in ancient
Rome
so how about this though right there's
it also stands to reason that any of the
stuff they have recovered is not
necessarily from the same time or place
and it's not necessarily the same alien
they could have all right they could
have 20 different types of aliens
different types of ships have landed
here and they're like oh we got another
one it's a bird an alligator all
different people that this alien didn't
even know about that alien right and
they're going what the right oh I'm
saying like the aliens who both landed
here like who what are you who are you
right yeah yeah yeah I was watching them
where the bus stop okay here's the
theories about CERN which is the the
thing that Jared said the collider
caused earthquakes by sending plasma
from Switzerland to Italy at high speeds
opening portals into hell or other
dimensions and Shifting the world into
an alternate timeline in 2015 CERN even
admitted it attempted to create tiny
black holes so scientists can study
antimatter CERN insists it's research
including that of microscopic black
holes is perfectly safe but some
theorists believe it could cause a
collapse of the entire
[Laughter]
that's crazy
what about the direct energy weapons you
know about those the dudes no don't have
direct energy weapons
too much direct this is hey babe direct
energy weapons they think that this has
actually been causing earthquakes and
hurricanes and they the governments of
the world are now can now truly control
the weather like truly Direct Energy
weapon damages I don't like that it's
due yeah lasers
the Jews got caught in this Crossfire
yes they were like oh the dudes
they supposedly been using them
countries have been using them and they
don't want to get it into the yeah the L
rad that's dangerous we need to
eradicate the deuce yeah we got it yeah
weapon that damages its Target from
Focus energy that sounds a little Jewish
to me it's very do uh yeah in it but in
all seriousness uh if we so let me let
me pose this question now we've talked
about this already but like if we're
able to capture them right because they
they didn't just crash and we have dead
ones right people have seen real ones
right so that means that we captured
them bird dogs bird dogs started with us
a while back yes and they just we tweet
they popped back in ruff ruff yep that's
their new their new logo their new uh
what sound bite for bird dogs should be
tweet tweet reference it should be tweet
ruff ruff and dude bird dogs they got
those khaki shorts that function they're
like the best pair of gym shorts you put
them on the material stretches around
you yes I the bird dog and I love that
they got the underwears in the shorts
and in the pants I literally I go
freaking Commando when the only thing is
is now my stains are directly on my
pants for you that's what happens well
bird dogs be comfortable as
comfortable as and they got this uh
ball sweat technology stuff where like
my nuts Wicks it away it's magic magic
shorts Dude Perfect Pants they sent me a
box they sent me a box it was like
Christmas yeah it's still made it's such
quality the way they make and if you
don't love birds and don't love dogs
then get away from me anyway so they
combine the two and you can get I dude
that's the thing you're going to get a
free tumbler with this promo code but
that tumbler that they send it to me
that's awesome it's what I use every day
every day and it keeps this stuff hot or
cold for like hours and it fits in the
cup holder that's important that's huge
go to birddogs.com hey babe and enter
promo code hey babe for a free Tumblr
with your order it's a quality one I
have two of them yes that's birddogs.com
hey baby promo code hey babe for the
free Tumblr and check out their clothing
yeah what's up everybody aliens are real
they finally got unveiled by Congress so
what better time to come see me do
stand-up comedy Chris D comedy.com for
Ticky Wiki's August we're in Atlantic
City September we're in La Portland
Seattle New York City baby Radio City
and theater at MSG and then Las Vegas to
round out September October we're back
in Los Angeles then we're in Nebraska
Kansas City St Louis Chicago Raleigh
North Carolina and then November go
check them out chrisdcomedy.com for
ticket wikis we also just put Nashville
and Washington DC on sale baby girl
if you're listening to this right now
and you are a natural I am here I'm
playing the opera house tonight with the
guys
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets
tomorrow we will be in uh the Cambridge
Field House in Indianapolis and we're
rallying out Saturday at the stifle
theater in St Louis for two shows grab
those but I am back on tour after that
because I'm filming my special in
Chicago in December and we are going to
be at the Hartford Funny Bone the
Syracuse Funny Bone the Albany Funny
Bone all by September and then we're
hitting Bowling Green Kentucky
Cincinnati Toledo Wilkes bar
Pennsylvania Wilmington
Macon Georgia which I was corrected
about many times Savannah Athens Georgia
I'm coming through you Mount Pleasant uh
there you go and then Peoria Rockford
Cedar Rapids Springfield Illinois Duluth
Minnesota Appleton Wisconsin which just
went on sale so you get those tickets to
still good ones Rochester Davenport and
Elkhart Indiana they're all on sale
right now they're all going to be before
the end of this year Sal vulcano comedy
dot com for tickets and you know what
check out some hey babe and uh some
taste buds merch on our website we got
some good merch so you should go there
if you're a fan and buy something don't
be okay so first of all if they have
access to viewing us uh for some time
they're more intelligent than us so why
why would they be able to land here even
in a crash which means that there are
faults in what they do but like then be
able to be captured and not communicate
back or overcome us if someone went to
them to detain them and they were these
beings that could well could be we
would have had a Intergalactic War
already maybe same as us maybe we're
like we don't want this guy going out
and talking to Congress they don't want
their guys talking to their people
they're like right we'll we'll go crazy
too right maybe there's like kind of
like an admission of like we can't
handle it you can't handle it keep to
your side and we'll keep to our side
because both of our species will go nuts
right so maybe that's a part of it where
they're like you if you get left there
we're leaving you're done like we can't
handle bringing you back or maybe there
like explorers like how our we would
have explorers that would go out like
people Magellan yeah
she's gone there's nothing we could do
maybe that's maybe there are the the
edge of the universe but you would think
with their Advanced Technologies whether
technologically or just within
themselves they'd be able to fight or
defend themselves the fact that we can
detain them says what that like we can
go walking with an alien in a fight I
think Chris might be right and the idea
that like like if Chris colum like the
day Chris Columbus came back do you
think they were like you're back like
they didn't get a cell phone call being
like hey I found this whole new land the
the Earth is round it's totally true he
had to come back and Report what had
happened right now
like a couple days after so like the
idea so like maybe that's it they like
we're waiting on them if they come back
yeah but I'm saying they're coming here
unarmed with no repair kit and also like
like I'm saying if they get out and it's
like they see people surrounding them
this other life because also it's then
to reason that maybe they're not
monitoring us you're like you're said
maybe this maybe the alien the first
time he landed here was she or the alien
I'm a signing gender already excuse me
no but I feel like that you're worried
about
the alien language yeah uh I don't want
to be canceled everywhere no this is
crazy no but but but I'm motivated I'm a
motivated alien yeah we should name the
episode unmative unmotivated dudes
but I would think that like they would
then be there well they might have not
known about Earth until they saw it and
crashed here and they haven't been
monitoring us right this is a mistake
but but they can they can create
something get here land here be sentient
of some sort and then not have the power
to defend themselves against like
a farmer yeah yeah somebody in our gay
military yeah what if they're like
National Park Rangers like they can't
defend themselves
right they're not the military
are there genetic composition is not
Superior then
um maybe they can't breathe in this
atmosphere I don't know I think this was
all I think to me this I I only see
these stories on Tick Tock like I've
never seen alien stories as much as I do
on Tech talk to me China just wants to
distract us this is this is their way
this is all we talk about now we're
doing Congress things like isn't there
an element of like yeah there's a
Chinese app I'm only seeing it there
they're like get them all around about
aliens they're like oh we'll get them
mad at each other there's no doubt
that's a trojan horse there's no doubt
right this is uh and they're like and
that you think back in China China's
like listen give them aliens and Matt
Rife
right and then it's over
I think there's anything like in China
being like hey tell me about the alien
no no one's there's no discussion right
yeah of like what did you see they're
like no get to work right yeah we're not
talking to everybody else about the
aliens yeah where's it feels like we're
just talking about it yeah why is it
like yes why is it like a French person
like oh let me tell him in yeah where's
the French course right yeah right we're
spending work days on this right
yeah which is we have things yeah
infrastructure why isn't Isis making a
statement
yeah
yeah sure yeah it's I don't know I feel
like again why have they only landed in
the United States they have to have
landed in other places right so like
where's this like don't you think that
should be they're saying there's been
treaties between between the government
and and well that's what Antarctica
brings up Antarctica is the only place
in the world where there is no all the
countries can just go into the same area
with no treaties no negotiations and
just do some type they all have like the
secret base that you can't go by that
every country is allowed into for some
reason really yeah can we talk about I
mean this is
scariest topic that isn't scary you know
people talk about this without fear now
like don't like I I I'm terrified I just
want my Netflix special to come out
right I mean August 15th
single like I you know
you know you go like with my kids I'm
like I'm like honestly you know the the
eight-year-old my two-year-old is you
know just whatever just running around
she's my two-year-olds her new things
she's running around going oh my
she's saying oh my combined oh my
God or no she goes oh my every
time you put her in the card scene and
the car starts she'll be sitting there
quiet and then as soon as you reverse
the car she goes oh my
it's like a catchphrase yeah yeah I love
it yeah and uh and so so she's whatever
and then my eight-year-old and 13 year
old they already like this would not
blow their minds because they're like
yeah I knew that already like they
already think they know that no but you
you're you're of the Mind where like
look you've lived your whole life the
history before us has not nothing's come
to fruition yet right so you're not
going to change gears and go there like
you're not gonna be like start to be
like a doomsday or no like has it gone
through your head now that like oh like
how do I protect my children no because
I don't think there's a way to I think
it when if that happens there's really
nothing I I can I can I can only control
are you a lizard person
I can only control what I can control so
I'm like I there's nothing I'm gonna be
able to do if that happens straight
honestly if one of us was an alien we
would not tell the other and we may not
know if one of us an alien I may not
even know I may have been programmer I
don't even know what I am I have no idea
I can't I can't really I can't go on
that we don't know if we're aliens I
can't go on you don't know anything you
could they say that the greatest
scientists in the world to Elon Musk of
the world say that is 99.5 chance where
we are a part of some kind of video game
but we're so the race has been so
Advanced that we have no way of knowing
that we're in the game I'm okay just let
me go to Olive Garden but that's part of
the game why do I have to be at the last
level right right I'd be in the 50s like
no like you know you go why
I'd rather be and do we think that we
will ever seize this in our life what
what generation is is everything going
to come out with like you know I mean is
it going to be in 50 years 500 years are
we gonna be around in the 500 years like
someone is going to be here that might
even be in your own lineage right that
is going to see some go down who's
The Unlucky One that the ball lands on
exactly the thing like I like let me go
to like I have this thing I'm like let
me just go to Turks and Caicos right
right I just want to see that beach yeah
I want to see my kid get married yeah
you know why can't I be that generation
aliens are like
yeah yeah I would have liked to have
been like look uh color television right
that
is surprised your daughter after you
pass could Witnesses and you'll never
know it I'll never know and that's the
thing is like I I so when you're asking
how do I think about it with my kids I'm
like I don't know I'm living in this
time I can't change it so I'm like
whatever they're they already feel more
prepared for this than I do they already
they are not this isn't good for our
brains that's what I keep thinking like
we like it's not negative though they
could come down and just it could be
Star Wars or Total Recall they could
just join Society I hope that's that you
know joint Society is like Star Wars
that's bad they blew up a planet well
Star Wars though they do code that was
become like a coalition
there's gonna be a subsection of aliens
that will like there goes the
neighborhood you can't even handle like
shades of skin color right right in what
world are we handling
I think that's why we're so pessimistic
we're like but what if this destroys
racism as a concept as a concept you
really hate the people not a race do you
think it's all Races it's all Races Now
versus the aliens or we just go oh we
didn't know anything else here's the
thing as human beings we're never not
going to be racist so it's either
against each other or against the other
things it's always just going to be that
again it becomes that thing of like
everyone goes deeper I think into their
thing they'll blame if they're racist
they'll blame other races if they're
well if they're a preacher they'll keep
preaching I watch this thing about like
you know like lineage and like Evolution
and it's like you know there are many
different types of humans Homo sapiens
which is what us but then it was like
you know the homo erectus the homo this
homo that homo whatever allegedly
allegedly and then and then but we are
the ones all of us no matter what color
we are we are the ones we are you know
uh uh kind of came from the most
dominant one the most evil Darwinism the
most aggressive one so we no matter what
we are if we're here we're from the most
aggressive aggressive lineage and
aggressive Evolution so it's in all of
us to be the meanest and the most
aggressive even the nice ones because
it's in us if it wasn't in us we
wouldn't be here we would have been died
off already right so it's this thing so
it's like this thing in us so I do want
to watch the kid the video of the kid
The Whistleblower also just said uh yeah
what is it who is this this kid looks
like a hey babe fan this is the teenage
son that witnessed that Vegas alien
thing because the guy in Congress just
now not taken down though no it's still
looking he's wearing a Simpson
sweatshirt I mean this is who we're
getting our news from
this kid is Snooki yeah
before we go to this that guy uh two
Congress said they have 100 known about
aliens since 1932. see 1932 because the
world war the world war the Nazi
technology that's what it's about during
the Great depressed
imagine those people even more depressed
the whole rate the whole thing
supposedly the whole thing about the
Nazis was they had they had the not they
had the the alien technology first and
that's why they were able to just
steamroll over every country in Europe
so quickly and then obviously they went
into the Holocaust and they
Hitler went off the rails but in the
beginning it was about we have this
technology and we're going to reverse
engineer this stuff and the uh and the
Western governments what did they get
from that they stopped the US didn't no
I well they uh people think that the
United States and the Western allies
stopped them and then we took it and
then we have it now but supposedly they
have so much gold because the thing is
with Germany after World War II they
didn't just like after World War One
Germany got decimated they were
decimated they were poor people were
dying in the streets that's why they had
to do World War II but after World War
II they remained one of the richest
countries and they are by far the
wealthiest country in Europe and nobody
knows how so and it's not talked about
how but they are yeah so they think it's
because they have this technology that
either they sold or something it's
something to do with alien technology
this is a really way to promote
Oppenheimer yeah yeah yeah this is crazy
did they were like you know what Barbie
crushed us so hard released
we don't need this what if Hitler was an
alien the whole time yeah he could have
been yeah but now he's down left is
right then yeah I don't know how to
function anymore
panic attack all right let's listen to
what this this kid kind of looks like
Casey Jones if he was from Pennsylvania
to me on May 1st 2023
I'm not trying to explain the best of my
abilities this is not a conspiracy
theory
I'm not making this story out for cloud
or fame
I just want to tell you what happened to
me and my family
and I know some people are not gonna
believe this but
each person is different
so this is what happened to me
keep in mind this is midnight and I'm
fixing a truck in my backyard The
Simpsons sweatshirt only with my brother
it's too much something fall from the
sky
I turn around the only thing I I see is
a big light falling from the sky and
moments after I feel a big impact and uh
yeah it was Ice sort of like a big
impact fall
and me and my brother looked at each
other and we were scared about the about
when the impact happened
it was sort of like a Shockwave
experience
so to say when I tried to look at the
object
area
and I hear thousands of footsteps around
me wait wait wait can you just back that
up a little bit please
and also you I do I don't get the sense
that he's taking us for a ride here I
think I see I see some genuine no this
kid is Jen I believe this kid so yeah so
why was he allowed to come on and say
that I think because he just uploaded
her onto YouTube aren't they gonna come
in their suits yeah this is on May 1st
by the way this is months and months old
so why are we only hearing about it now
no we already we talked about it I just
didn't play for you all right so when
did we talk about it briefly months
months ago can our listeners listen to
this yeah yeah I'm gonna edit it but
it's okay that we they listen to this oh
yeah yeah this is a moment
my parents parents like never on that
they like go on once a day on their
computer right and they see like
Congress talked about aliens and that's
all they see right we are we are on a
YouTube video the guy in a Simpsons
sweatshirt telling us about aliens
freaking ourselves out on a cruise in
Italy yeah you know what we're gonna do
for lunch yeah straight up first hand
account right
well let's watch it so to say when I try
to look see that's what I didn't
understand he heard just a few it was
all blurry now my vision but only the
backyard area
and I hear thousands of footsteps around
me and maybe a couple seconds later the
blurriness was gone
and here's here's the footage of the
body
the police officer's body Cam and here's
the objects on the object I'm referring
to the light
video
okay
so where's the light in the back that
back in the sky oh the Dead one dead
center that huge green light here's a
ring camera video you could hear the
bang
this is around the neighborhood so
here's the video
[Music]
so that's the bang that's the bang or it
could have just been a do but when that
happened the only thing I can see in the
backyard is a top creature probably
around Jews are known to be in that
neighborhood
and he saw the same thing the same
creature I saw
he told me to go inside the house at
this point we all freaking out me and my
family
and here's the video where we were in
the backyard area you can see you cannot
see it too good but on camera but it's
there here's the video
the fact that they're even standing
there right I think where was the thing
comes out of the video me and my brother
went to go pick up my tools
pick up your tools
so I look
keep in mind I'm facing the forklift
and then I see the alien creature
so when I saw it creature it was a tall
skinny lengthy creature it was a gray
greenish color
and when I looked that in the eyes my
body just froze my body just froze like
the same way the same experience as
having sleep houses keep in mind I'm
staring at him and I look at his whole
body and he has a weird looking feet and
a big face and eyes and you can see a
big mouth
and and I I could hear his loss deep
breathing and I could see his stomach
moving breathing he would just stare at
me seconds later I can start moving
again
and I start running towards the house
that's when I called 9-1-1 and here's
the 9-1-1 call
there's like an eight foot person beside
it and another one's inside and it has
big eyes and looking at us and it's so
good
[Music]
it's got a Char it's got a charger
yeah
you better in your backyard
correct and they're very large
nine feet
even stand there being like maybe I
should get my big eyes
[Music]
tools
[Laughter]
he's like I had my favorite rice
didn't want to miss my favorite would
you go back to your phone I'd go back
for my phone I'd go back for my phone
Whispering like oh my God I would go
back
on the roof
so we waited a little bit for the police
when they arrived and they told me what
I told them what I saw
and they were kind of freaked out here's
the body cam of the officer and now it's
more than an hour after that bright
light officers meeting up with the
caller and his family what'd you see it
was like a
it was like a big creature a big
creature yeah like an old testing top
we're not going to BS you guys one of my
partners said they saw something
following the sky too so that's why I'm
kind of curious did you see anything
land in your backyard or they see like a
big that's what they say they see like a
big uh like a big something would like
what I saw right now I do believe in it
police walk into the backyard to
investigate but Metro so they went in
the backyard and one of the officers
pointed at the floor and it was a
perfect circle here's a photo of the
circle police walk into the backyard to
investigate but Metro so they went in
the backyard and one of the officers
pointed out the floor and it was a
perfect circle here's a photo of the
circle I'm referring to
where's the circle damn keep in mind
it's pretty perfect I came in my house
and one of them started running to his
car driving around the neighborhood
asking passing cars at the salt light
what's clear they're taking this call
seriously hey this might sound like a
really dumb question but did you guys
see anything fall out of the sky asking
others what they saw uh I would normally
discounted as nothing however
um
seen as one of my partners said they saw
it too the only reason I'm actually
investigating further
Goosebumps are freaking out he started
investigating that he told me his
partner she saw a light falling from the
sky he told me he believes me because
her partner reported that she saw the
same light as me now we're walking the
front yard then the other officer came
here here and here isn't there a point
in this where you go where are the
parents but what but like why isn't the
pain you say like I'll make the video
like why is the kid yeah but also the
video also were they gone when the cops
got there so they were gone
so they crashed but then
then well but then but then they called
the police and then they left do you
think so they only came quickly
aliens if they crashed and they're out
looking around and stuff they then they
mean they got back in and left because
they got no one's yeah they did they
must not have crashed then
or the other one there's a doctor Dr
Stephen Greer I think it's Dr Steven
Greer what he thinks what he thinks the
technology actually is is that they have
technology to be able to be on their
planet and almost if you can imagine
like cast their Shadows but basically
it's like their Shadows where they're
moving from like a safety of a pod but
they all can touch you and be physical
but it's not really them like that's
what they have some kind of technology
to do and he thinks that it's all it's
all like their what like when we how
would we have by well it could be a
different alien well he says he if those
ones you have like there you don't have
anything real of them you have like
their capsule like you're not gonna get
them because they don't ever leave where
they are that's like in Guardians of the
Galaxy
would do from home right and then they
would drive them like video games right
well I'm starting to believe that
anything that Hollywood puts out like
that is in some way real because they're
so connected to the top levels of the
government the top people in Hollywood
that they get creative the
conspiratorial Jew stuff that's what it
is Chris this is Chris this is what it
is leaning into you know his group here
100 I know my due history
how do you just go back to life after
that like he went back he slept that
night well he got his tools so he had he
went back to work
yeah at the end this tools were his to
keep that's it do you remember that from
when we were younger guys like at Apex
Technical remember those commercials
those local commercials oh yeah he was
like I can't call you pick up the phone
and call us today and your tools are
yours to keep it was on every single
commercial break for like 10 years yeah
and DeVry remember DeVry was big the big
big big
TV I mean that's it there's aliens you
can listen get abducted by aliens and
when you get abducted you can watch
Jared for each special on Netflix August
15th August 15th with the aliens you
know they'll relate to it 37 and single
watch it now baby the Jews are coming
one way or another I got some material
about dues on there
I got some you know stuff about body
confidence and yeah dating and
relationships all that and gender
reveal parties what about any of the
plugs besides the where can they find
you yeah Jared freed on Instagram the uh
podcast is uh every Wednesday and Sunday
so yeah go check it out but go watch the
special you guys will like it and it's
all fun and games it's all you know like
you guys it's like well we're not here
for you buddy thank you man it's really
very very excited my day Jared and I
started comedy together so I can vouch
yeah he's a good dude yeah
[Laughter]
my name
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe